[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
site we want to begin this evening with
an update on the world's dullest
impeachment trial it's ongoing right now
as you can see on the screen if
something significant happens obviously
we'll bring it to you right away
but the question is why has this been so
boring well because it doesn't mean
anything rather than a debate over
things that matter you're watching
purported adults yell at each other
about whether a former vice president
sneer do well middle aged son should
interrupt his early retirement in LA and
come talk to them honestly who cares
whatever but for once we do have a semi
interesting developments and apparently
some Democratic senators are now
considering casting votes to acquit
Donald Trump new report suggests that
senators joe Manchin of West Virginia
Kyrsten Sinema of Arizona and Doug Jones
of Alabama are undecided on the
president's guilt okay that's a story
undecided how could they be undecided
about this it's not like it's a totally
fraudulent exercise in partisan politics
no not at all if you've been watching
all week you know this is nothing less
than and we want to be totally clear
about this a national security crisis
President Trump is a clear and present
danger to our free and fair elections
and our national security the president
is an ongoing threat to our national
security the president betrayed our
national security and undermine the
security of our elections Donald Trump
has been and remains a threat to our
national security
he undermined America's national
security and compromised our national
security so that he could keep power he
harmed America's national security we
must act without delay did you hear that
are you listening carefully you're
taking notes the president undermined
American national security and he did it
on purpose you know what that is it's
treason as they'll tell you on Twitter
but here's a question what about the
people who have bet the under minors of
American national security who refused
to stop or punish or convict them aren't
they guilty of treason - of course they
are at the very least they're
collaborators in fact it might not be
long before we're watching the
impeachment trials of Joe Manchin Doug
Jones in Kyrsten Sinema because ladies
and gentlemen
let's not forget what is at stake here
it's not simply America that was
betrayed by Donald Trump's notorious
phone call it was perhaps far more
importantly the noble people of Ukraine
the Ukrainians as we call them our most
important allies in the global war
against putinism listen to noted America
defender Adam Schiff explained the
widely accepted fact of Ukraine's
importance to our national security
makes president Trump's abuse of power
and withholding of vital diplomatic and
military support all the more disturbing
if we had not supported Ukraine in 2014
it would have weakened our allies and
exposed us troops stationed in Europe to
greater danger
we only deter Russia by consistently
demonstrating support for our friends
friends like Ukraine that is why it is
so important to our security that we
stand with Ukraine countries like
Ukraine are fighting our fight against
authoritarianism and god help us if it's
not our fight still god help us implores
America's warrior priest Adam Schiff
stand with Ukraine for the love of God
man stand with Ukraine as generations of
men on their deathbeds have said to
their oldest sons boy stand with Ukraine
because even now in this modern age that
we dare to call civilized there are dark
forces lurking unseen in the shadows
even now forces that if left to their
own diabolical devices might briefly
delay the transfer of sophisticated
weapons technology the but knighted
people of that holy nation Ukraine and
that as Cory Booker once explained with
a totally straight face would be treason
now we're realizing that this president
was withholding that aid not for
national security purposes in fact
violating national security interests to
pursue his own personal benefit that is
outrageous and in my opinion that is
treasonous treasonous so really the
question at this point is what do you do
with treason do you look away and
pretend you don't see it do you let
treason pass with a vote of acquittal
not unless you're a coward a worm a
betrayer not unless unlike every decent
red blood
an American you don't really love
Ukraine with the selfless love of a
parent for a child nonetheless you're
the kind of soul dead monster would put
the interest of your nation above those
of Ukraine did you know that Chicago
Illinois is the sister city of Kiev not
a first cousin mind you I don't know a
sister that's how close though
physically distant Ukraine is
spiritually near effectively the 51st
state when Ukraine sneezes we as a
nation say God bless you when the
Ukrainian people stumble we bruise we
are one Ukraine in us just as we have
been for centuries upon centuries what
Adam Schiff has joined together let no
man put asunder so think about that joe
manchin Kyrsten Sinema